Minha cabeça tá fo você se criou cedaps
aqui que não tinham acontecido
antes por isso que eu te falei que é uma
ideia de milhões hoje eu acho eu acho
não eu sei que 25% das pessoas que
trabalham na minha empresa não deveriam
trabalhar na empresa inteligências
artificiais deveriam tá Deia mais de
25% e hoje assim qual que o cara que
quer utilizar Inteligência Artificial
assim vamos sei lá pegar um gestor de
tráfego que quer utilizar inteligência
artificial no negócio pensando em alguém
comum assim qual que é o caminho que
esse cara deveria dar para usar
Inteligência Artificial assim E qual
seria esse passo a passo na minha visão
cara pô primeiro muito prazer Valeu aí
pelo seu tempo muito muito obrigado por
tá falando aqui comigo eh vou reforçar
ali cara
começou apareceu um vídeo seu de um
podcast gigante na minha frente eu dei
play como quem não quer nada e não
consegui parar de ver até o último
minuto e normalmente eu me distraio mais
então foi o foi do vitur ou do do S
groselia lá foi do cara é o fundinho de
de de tijolinho tá então foi o Vit fo
Camp é foi muito foi muito muito muito
bom assim pô eu curti muito seu conteúdo
e aí eu falei pô vou dar uma olhada e
cara eu é uma coisa que eu
tô a gente tem uma empresa a gente tem
empresa Grande a gente tá inclusive
agora assim contratando um c novo pra
empresa é uma vaga bem difícil da gente
gentec ocupar e E aí cara tô a gente tá
contratando esse c show eu acho que a
gente encontrou a pessoa e ele é um cara
assim que pô Entende é aquilo né só que
entende bastante é sempre relativo eu
nunca comparado a quem né mas é uma
pessoa que aparentemente entende muito
mais do que eu sobre esse Universo de
inteligências artificiais é eu acho que
o o mundo ainda tá muito
na nas ranhuras na na super fí ainda do
do poder que esse negócio tem e e assim
quando eu escuto alguém falando e eu não
entendo metade das palavras que a pessoa
falou eu sub entendo que essa pessoa
sabe mais do que eu no meu no meu caso
foi isso com você você começou a falar
assim não sei o que primeiro eu peguei
um corte os agentes eu falei velho What
the fuck is um agente O que que é uma
[__] de um agente eu fiquei tentando
entender aí eu descobri que a empresa do
Maluco é BR o João né que o é que o
maluco é brasileiro aí falei p o maluco
é brasileiro que tipo é o agente é meio
que uma automação mas que não é só uma
automação é mais do que uma automação
vai além disso então assim eh eu eu
pirei assim pirei na batatinha e eu cara
eu queria muito
eh perguntar para ti assim É eu sei que
é uma resposta um tanto quanto complexa
de de se dar assim mas hoje eu acho eu
acho não eu sei que 25% das pessoas que
trabalham na minha empresa não deveriam
trabalhar na minha empresa inteligên
artificiais deveriam est talvez você vai
jogar esse número até para um valor mais
alto mas eu acredito muito nisso e só
que é meio que assim por por onde que
você por onde que você começa a a olhar
para esse para esse universo assim
porque pra maioria das pessoas
Inteligência Artificial e até até para
mim assim não é pra maioria das pessoas
eu tô na maioria das pessoas me coloco
nesse caldo comum é tipo eu chat GPT
entendeu É você sei lá ma das pessoas é
isso é criar prompt Zinho é simplesmente
hã fazer ou pegar aquelas imagens
aqueles aplicativos de imagenzinha né
tipo assim que só troca o rosto da
pessoa a maioria da galera é isso é tipo
é um hypezinho e que não não gera
resultado financeiro né tá E e hoje
assim qual que o cara que quer utilizar
Inteligência Artificial assim vamos sei
lá pegar um gestor de tráfego que quer
utilizar inteligência artificial no
negócio pensando em alguém comum assim
qual qual que é o caminho que esse cara
deveria dar para usar Inteligência
Artificial assim porque beleza por mais
que seja Prom petzinho ainda assim tem
muita gente que nem cara não é um não é
um user entendeu ele não usa ali
diariamente a inteligência artificial e
tá ali tipo assim sei lá eu lembro que
outro dia eu falei pro cara assim ah o
cara falou ah não sei fazer prompt eu
falei [__] pergunta pro J pd como é que
faz um BRT entendeu Tipo usa ferramenta
para usar a ferramenta aí o cara meio tá
ligado Tipo explodiu a cabeça falei mas
isso é uma coisa meio idiota assim mas
nem esse tipo de sagacidade as pessoas
tem tem assim e aí quando eu vejo você
falando de Agentes eu fico pensando
assim pois iso é um passo muito avançado
ou não cara não é uma coisa realmente
simples assim eu acho que o passo pra
pessoa aprender a usar ela primeiro
criar os gpts dela o que que você acha
assim que é pô esse aqui é um caminho
legal assim é um caminho para uma pessoa
leiga um cara que tá entrando na
internet hoje ganhar int usar a
inteligência artificial Não sei se esse
caminho existe mas enfim eu tô tentando
uma pergunta aqui para trair um pouco de
informação dessa sua cabeça pensante S
eu eu tenho uma frase que não é minha
que que também não é do cara que eu
peguei que seria do cap gupta que todo
processo leva mediocridade não existe
processo para a grandeza então assim PR
para T se tornar muito poder ático não
vai existir um passo a passo mas tem ter
um passo a passo para pelo menos est por
exemplo assim talvez Acima da Média ou
realmente aprender E qual seria esse
passo a passo na minha visão é primeiro
começar ah entendendo um pouquinho de
engenharia de prompt e assim quando a
gente fala engenharia de promt parece
que é algo engenharia algo não é é
conversar não um bagulho n é tipo assim
Nossa vou ter que aprender matemática
avançada não sei o que lá não
programação entendeu programação não
precisa inclusive Quando tu tenta
colocar a programação lá no meio do
código prompt né nem funciona direito
porque ela é uma linguagem natural então
assim é conversar e daí que vem o
problema maior que eu acho que é eh para
que você consiga extrair o máximo da
máquina você precisa ter clareza e a
maioria das pessoas não tem clareza
então desenvolver a capacidade de
clareza é algo que te faz ter um
controle muito grande do que é possível
fazer e é por isso que eu costumo falar
eu tentei ensinar essas coisas mais
avançadas para para por exemplo
Funcionários das empresas mas essa
galera não tem a clareza que um por
exemplo você que é o empresário tem
então normalmente é o melhor cara para
se aprender sobre a e sobre essas coisas
é o empresário não é é meio
contrapartida porque tipo não mas eu
devia botar alguém que que estudar Isso
B tal é isso que eu eu mas eu tô
pensando nisso aí você me tipo assim Car
Você cagou com a minha teoria não é
botar alguém que vai estudar isso né
Pode até ser mas é pode ser tipo assim
mas alguém que vai ser operacional tá
assim alguém que vai ser operacional por
exemplo assim tu não precisa tu tá ali
na no Python escrevendo agentes no Crew
ai ou configurando por exemplo alguma
coisa isso não precisa mas na hora de
pensar principalmente no prompt ou
pensar na estrutura tem que ser o
empresário porque assim a inteligência
por trás do negócio vem de ti então
assim a inteligência ela vem do pedido é
isso aí que você tá é tipo daquilo que
eu quero e aí isso vem na minha clareza
de onde ex ex que eu tô precisando ex
por que que tu tem o que tu tem porque
tu teve clareza de saber executar aquilo
por exemplo assim cara vou fazer fazer
Live as quartas-feiras vou divulgar vou
fazer é uma clareza que tu tem que se tu
contratar uma pessoa essa pessoa ela já
teria digamos ela não seria contratada
por ti se ela tivesse a capacidade da
tua clareza entendeu E o cara e muitas
vezes a pessoa que olha de fora não
consegue entender o que que tá dentro né
tipo assim não consegue tanto que tipo
assim eu tento extrair isso o máximo
possível aqui não sei quantos quantas
pessoas tu tem hoje no tu aqui 220 Nossa
é muita gente eu diria mais de
25% [__] é muita gente meu tipo assim
eu já tive uma empresa com 80 pessoas e
assim já era um caos agora tô com 45 eu
já tô [__] devia ter criado mais ag
gente é mais é mais fácil comandar
inteligências artificiais pessoas
né Seguindo a linha aqui vamos seguir a
linha bem lógica Tu já percebeu que eu
sou eu sou um cara voado então assim eu
tá mas eu eu percebi que eu eu gostei da
sua cabeça metódica também engenharia de
prompt e e clareza clareza dentro da
engenharia de prompt tem assim a
primeira coisa Qualquer por exemplo ass
tu vai pegar uma coisa que para estudar
pra galera que eu falo assim cara tu
quer estudar e aprender esses negócios É
só abrir a documentação da Open Eye
Abrir documentação do clou do antropic e
abrir documentação por exemplo ã sei lá
do de uma outra do Lhama por exemplo so
essas documentações e tu é o cara que
fala bastante sobre isso né ler
documento lá do do do do Facebook mas
esses documentos eles são tipo assim ele
é um texto normal ele não é tipo toda
vez que alguém fala documentação eu você
é legal que que eu tô falando isso para
você porque como você ensina isso eu vou
te trazer as dúvidas que as pessoas têm
que às vezes você não sabe que as
pessoas têm cara quando você fala
documentação de Open and para mim Parece
que o bagulho que eu vou abrir um
negócio é um e é um código tipo assim
parece que eu vou ler programação
entendeu vou falar assim não não vou
abrir tá aqui vou compartilhar minha
tela contigo aqui tá vendo minha tela aí
nãoé uhum tá então tem doc aqui ó pal
antropic
ó
ó tá tem um document cara essa
documentação é maravilhosa maravilhosa
ele te explica sobre a ferramenta te
explica tudo não só sobre a ferramenta
mas os conceitos por trás da ferramenta
então por exemplo antropic é o do clou a
se você conhece o cloud mas ele é a uma
dasas mais também conhecido como
Claudião é do CL então aqui ele é cara
tipo assim absurdo ele tem 200 mil
tokens não sei se sabe o que é o token
mas o token Basic é uma unidade de
memória como fosse uma memória RAM só
que ele é uma unidade de memória então o
token ele não é só por exemplo deixa eu
abrir aqui sobre tokenização
ti vou dar um minicurso rápido de tentar
te ensinar em 15 minutos aqui
ótimo
to Beleza então o token ele não
simplesmente é por exemplo vou pegar
esse próprio texto aqui vou jogar aqui ó
e ele já vai mapear o token não
significa que é um caracter ou que é uma
palavra o token é um pedaço dentro do
sistema então assim por exemplo nesse
sistema aqui ó Open é um token ai é um
token isso aqui ó é um token large
entendeu então aqui a gente tem 141
tokens e tem 682 caracteres mais ou
menos ah cada token seria equivalente a
oito caracteres Mas é uma conta tipo
assim de padaria sabe tá entend agora
beleza então assim imagina que aqui esse
cara aqui ele tem 200.000 tokens isso
significa o quê vamos multiplicar por
oito dá ali 800 por 8 dá 100 1.6 é então
assim 1.6
ã 1000 É é tipo assim Beleza então isso
significa o quê é que eu posso
basicamente jogar um livro aqui porque
ele consegue ler Ah seria oito vezes o
número de de palavras na verdade então
daria para jogar um livro dentro ele vai
conseguir conversar comigo como se fosse
o livro inteiro o que que é interessante
por exemplo desse cara aqui por exemplo
se tu tem agora vamos trazer pro mundo
de tráfego Inclusive eu tô criando uma
de tráfego se tu pega aqui e joga dentro
desse cara aqui
ã uma campanha por exemp de 60 dias 90
dias um monte de planilha ele vai ter a
capacidade de fazer essa leitura porque
ele tem espaço na memória dele para
fazer isso tá o chat chpt não tem não
porque tipo assim o chat GPT ele tem o
chpt até pouco tempo atrás ele tinha
4000 agora ele depois ele subiu para 16
agora ele tá com 32 então ele tem 32
versus 200000 é muita coisa é muita
diferença o [__] Então é isso eu eu vou
tá esse cara aqui assim ele é [__] assim
tem o 128k do chat só que ele só é
acessível via pi vou explicar também o
que é isso assim como é que funciona eu
sei você sabe que pi digo assim como
funciona essa parte do da aqui vou
tentar te ensinar tipo assim e One on
One tipo assim em 15
minutos aqui que que eu falei desse cara
aqui é interessante porque eles ess
entações aqui ó aqui ó tem prompt
Library basicamente tem eles mostram
como é que isso aqui é bem novo como é
que eles vários prompts que eles a
empresa mesmo tip assim criou para te
poder guiar então isso aqui é
maravilhoso porque tipo assim que legal
não não tá aprendendo com falando de tal
sabe eu ensino inclusive meus alunos com
esses pros aqui com com as coisas que
são originais da própria e aqui tem uma
parte que faz quando eu tento criar uma
uma conta no no claudão ele diz que
Cloud a is only available só no Brasil
só só é só Unidos ou Inglaterra por isso
que eu criei a minha própria ia aqui ó
tem todos as ias do mundo tipo aqui tu
consegue acessar o
Code
mixama oama é esse é o que o meta tá
usando né é o do meta e assim tá absurdo
ti a gente tá testando com os agentes
aqui que daí eu posso rodar no meu
próprio PC né não preciso nem usar
internet e aqui por exemplo aqui minha
ia aqui já tem o TR né e tal mas aqui
então beleza assim formma de acessar o
CL ai ou através de um sistema meu aqui
um app como meu ou através api se não tá
liberada para pessoas é esse é pt o
mesmo então esse é é meu e daí tem eu tô
desenvolvendo várias também expansão
gigantesca eu criei uma Startup aqui uma
uma Hold de startups eu tô com vários
startups de app porque chega muita coisa
para mim e aqui o clou como é que tu vai
acessar quero acessar esse cara aqui
igual tu tá vendo aí eh tu vai ter que
usar ou Peg para alguém de repente um
dos teus funcionários mora fora do
Brasil foi o que acon mora fora
não eu não moro mas Digamos um
funcionário teu mora fora Ah deve ter
alguém que mora fora não tem tem então
pede para esse cara foi o que aconteceu
comigo eu tenho um funcionário meu que
ele é programador em Londres ele é tipo
você faz faz an sistemas em Londres e
daí eu pedi para ele criar lá porque
sinceramente eu fiquei três meses
tentando criar essa merda eu eu tentei
Criar e quando eu tava nos Estados
Unidos inclusive não consegui porque
eles ficam pegando um monte de
referência de IP não sei o que lá então
tá mas se ele criar lá eu consigo logar
por aqui consegue logar porque tipo é só
criar depois tu loga em qualquer lugar é
só criar passar o cartão ó logo em
qualquer lugar
Ah então vai ter acesso já esse aqui que
é ele é assim extremamente superior ao
chat pt em Inúmeras coisas inúmeras por
mais que eles atualizaram faz duas
semanas que eles atualizaram o chat PT
novo mas mesmo assim ele o CL J ele
supera inúmeras vezes o principalmente
PR criação de cop textos criativos né
criativos de anúncio tu joga aqui uma
[__] de anúncio para ele aqui para
ele criar ele vai fazer muito melhor que
chpt E aí essa criação que você tá
dizendo é ess essa parte de pedir para
ele é o que você chama de a engenharia
de prompt e a melhor maneira que você
falou de entender sobre engenharia de
prompt é é ser nerdola sentar aí e cara
senta a bunda na cadeira e estuda essa
[__] ou estudar Isso aqui ou ou tipo
assim estudar o que eu ensino tipo assim
eu ress simplifico né daí tipo assim que
é o que eu ensino aqui pra galera deixa
eu ver aqui
formação daí aqui basicamente o que eu
tô fazendo é simplificar
simplificar PR galera mastigar pras
pessoas a formação mastigar Mas tu quer
tipo assim ter acesso tá E esse povo que
tu tá formando aí eles eles vão eles
estão usando para eles ou é um povo que
atende o mercado de trabalho ou dos dois
mas tem uma proporção assim não pô a
maioria é o povo que tá usando para si
próprio eu vou te dizer que a maioria
que entra aqui eu não consigo eu tenho
ten inclusive pesquisas aqui tipo assim
todas as pesquisas de que que tá para
que que vai fazer não sei o que
lá eu diria que tá bem repartido assim ó
é uns 30% são profissionais liberais que
querem substituir a equipe né tipo assim
cara não tu aguento mais ficar essa
rotação aqui tá essa rotação de
atendimento essa rotação de gente para
fazer tal coisa e nunca faz direito e
tal por exemplo tem um cara que ele
tinha o Gilberto ele tem um ele é ele é
ele é sócio meu também agora e ele tem
ele tem uma empresa nos Estados Unidos
que fatura mais de 100 milhões de
dólares por ano eh e a gente é amigo
desde do ofili do Brasil 2016 e ele
falou cara não aguento mais tipo assim
oi old times é old times daí tipo assim
ele é um cara que tipo assim ele não
aguentava mais F contratando assistente
daí eu até repostei agora no meus
Stories que ele finalmente tipo assim
ele tá com várias vias ali que foram
fazendo tudo para ele compra passagem Ah
faz booking de hotel faz pedido Food
para ele sabe tipo assim ele criou um
negócio qu um Jarvis para ele já ali ele
tá mais avançado que a nossa parte
assistente pessoal porque ele ficou eu
ensinei fui ensinando as coisas para ele
Fui nessa nessa vertente mas aí tipo
assim tem tem gente que pega Ah eu quero
fazer automação aqui uma parte da minha
cop ou sei lá quero ajuda na parte de
análise por exemplo até tenho bastante
gestores de tráfego meu ali Ah quero
quero ficar automatizando algumas coisas
de análise de de relatórios e daí tem a
galera que entra pro mercado de trabalho
cara eu quero chegar aqui e aprender
esses negócios para poder dar
consultoria esses caras eu tô indicando
eles para outras pessoas mas o que
acontece os melhores é tão é uma demanda
tão grande deve ter sentido isso né tipo
assim e aí engraçado é até legal porque
tipo assim depois eu posso pegar algumas
dicas contigo porque eu tô fazendo um tr
proo que tu já já fez que é o qu tu era
o cara do TR eu tô sendo meio que o cara
da ia agora né tipo assim
pessoal e assim daí começa a chegar Um
monte de gente pedindo serviço para mim
e eu não tenho tempo para atender essa
galera e daí eu criei uma uma agência
própria para atender essa galera e daí
começou a chegar muita gente tip assim
eu cheguei a fechar mais de 400.000 de
de contatos em uma semana [__] é um
negócio muito grande vou botar isso aqui
numa operação maior que tenha escritório
e alguém toque e daí essa galera as Mel
As melhores pessoas dentro da minha
formação eu contrato para mim porque eu
tô em muita demanda que eu conso melhor
né então tô trazendo muita gente [__]
para mim para abrir negócios e tal e
deve ter acontecido isso contigo né
também tipo assim não 100% 100% 100%
100% então assim a galera que chega para
Então acho que é meio parecido com o que
aconteceu contigo vai ter gente por
exemplo na na tua comunidade entrou
gente que era que era o cara que é
lançador tava cansado de ter o o gestor
de tráfego que não fazia as coisas
direito entrou gente uma profissão nova
entrou gente por exemplo que já
trabalhava no negócio então eu acho que
é meio parecido com o teu negócio também
sabe assim se for pensar então É mas é
uma por isso que eu te perguntei Até
porque eu fiquei curioso porque essa
linha de eh pode ser um pode ser um um
um Job né pode pode tipo assim ser uma
pode igual é uma uma gestão de de Ai
entendeu Tipo assim não sei qual que vai
ser o nome aqui é gestor eu tô chamando
de gestor gestor de a tipo assim é mas
Ah tem vários nomes até só dentro aqui
tem umas 10 profissões novas que foram
criadas enquanto eu tava dando porque a
formação Comecei em novembro quava nos
Estados Unidos
e começou a crescer muito rápido daí
tipo assim hoje já tem aqui Engenheiro o
formo né pessoas que saem daqui eles
formam são Engenheiros de promos
são são Engenheiros G etl que seria
extração tratamento e carregamento de
dados ou cientista não é um cientista de
dados mas é um cara que por exemplo
assim imagina um cara pegar todas as
tuas aulas cara isso é é um negócio que
eu posso pedir pro meu time fazer e tu
vai curtir fazer assim vou fazer para só
para te ver vou pedir o cara pegar todas
suas aulas que esse é um cara que
entende de dados extrair de ti a forma
como tu fala extrair o teu conhecimento
botar numa ia e todos os seus alunos
poderem conversar com essa ia tá isso
daí mas tá beleza eu eu ia eu ia isso
isso tá na minha na minha lista de de
perguntas aqui isso daí é uma coisa que
exige muitas horas de trabalho para
fazer isso porque assim eu tenho zilhões
de vídeos zilhões de explicações um
curso gravado que que eu tenho que fazer
para extrair essa inteligência Ah eu
tenho que pegar e pedir para uma
inteligência artificial transcrever aí
eu vou no chat GPT e crio um GPT meu e
jogo todas essas transcrições lá e falo
GPT esse daqui o Pedro falando e dando
aula é uma coisa mais ou menos nessa
linha ou não Não cara é tipo assim o
bagulho é muito mais embaixo do que tu
Tá imaginando é que para mim não é mas é
que nem para ti por exemplo entender é é
mais embaixo é bem mais embaixo assim
levou meses para eu entender isso vamos
ser sincero tipo assim levou meses para
eu conseguir fazer isso porque tu tem
que essas informações tuas Elas têm que
ser armazenadas da forma certa em banco
vetoriais não é nem banco normal sabe um
banco esql que é um banco normal o banco
normal é como se fosse uma planilha do
do do Excel do Excel tá o banco vetorial
é um banco com múltiplas dimensões então
tipo assim ele não tem só eixo X e Y
como tem né colunas e ele vai ter eixos
e números então é um banco vetorial esse
banco vetorial banco Asi consegue
encontrar informações com base em
parâmetros então tu tem que pegar todas
essas tuas informações tratar elas
porque não adianta jogar de qualquer
jeito porque esses esses pedaços
chamados de chunks eh eles T que ser no
tamanho correto e da forma correta para
I poder trazer até por uma questão de
economia de tokens porque imagina o
seguinte uma aula toda de 1 hora 1 hora
e meia isso dá mais do que 200.000
tokens que é o limite hoje dasas tem o
Gemini que é o do Google que tem 1.5
milhões de tokens mas ele não é muito
bom ainda mas mas a gente tá indo por
esse caminho né de ter milhões de tokens
Mas então tipo assim não adianta pegar
simplesmente que jpt n vai conseguir
entender uma aula tua por quê Porque ele
vai ter 32.000 tokens vai ele vai cortar
daí ele começa a alucinar que é uma
coisa que tu deve ter notado já quando
ela começa aí ela começa a falar um
monte merda Por que que ela alucina ou
tu aumentou demais a temperatura dela e
daí ela fica muito aleatória ou tu ela
faltou informações com base naquilo que
tu trouxe e ela tem que continuar
completando as frases ela vai ficar
viajando a batatinha daí então quando
tem tá ou ela ou ela trava né tipo assim
eu já tentei sei lá usar aquele Vox sei
lá transcrever um vídeo que era de uma
hora porque eu queria a transcrição dele
e ela morria no meio entendeu aí você
tem que fazer um novo request um novo
request um novo request um novo request
tá exatamente então assim o que que é o
que daí vem o essa essa função
basicamente eu eu digo assim e fazer se
[__] em ato tem que dominar duas coisas
apenas entre aspas n apenas porque são
dois universos né engenharia de prompt e
tratamento de dados para I que se chama
etl tá E esse tratamento de dados é um
bagulho assim você faz isso ou não Ah
não isso é uma tipo maneira disse que eu
eu tenho pessoas que fazem isso hoje eu
tenho pessoas que fazem isso hoje
inclusive contratei contratei cientista
de dados mesmo cara tipo assim
pós-graduado etc Ah tem a lista de dados
esse cara de Londres tá vindo pro Brasil
para trabalhar comigo agora Ah e eu
gosto de fazer também uma coisa que eu
gosto de fazer porque é uma coisa bem
nerdão né tipo assim de de ficar ah mas
é um rolê meio programação assim eu não
consigo Sabe quando alguém fala assim ah
criaram um anúncio a pessoa toda a
pessoa fica assim cara como assim eu não
consigo nem entender onde que é E aí eu
explicar é uma ferramenta você aperta
aqui nesse botão essa essa deixa te
mostrar deixa te mostrar em tempo real
fazendo etl que tipo assim pra gente ver
que não é tão não é não é um bicho de
sete cabeças depois que tu criou
metodologias e eu criei essas
metodologias eu vou fazer at no teu
vídeo aqui agora você e na formação você
ensina isso eu ensino isso aqui ó deixa
eu pegar aqui um vídeo teu vamos lá tá
Pedro
sobrão aí ó que tem uma hora e pouco tá
então tem assim qual que a forma eu
gosto de eu faço isso no caso por por
programação né mas eu vou fazer de uma
forma visual para te poder enxergar tudo
que tá acontecendo Então assim eu tenho
aqui um plugin que se chama YouTube subt
download helper eu ten eu tenho que te
confessar uma coisa eu eu tava muito
curioso para saber o que que era esse
plugin porque eu eu adoro ver os plugins
que as pessoas têm tipo assim eu vi ali
que você tem o o o rzinho ali
doer é aí eu falei eu adoro eu já falou
assim ah essa pessoa manja de de usar
como que usa a internet direito tá aí
esse plugin aí ele faz o quê ele vai
transformar o que em texto ele vai
transformar a tu a legenda do teu canal
aqui em texto tá então vou baixar aqui
tipo assim achei então aqui tá a legenda
só que tu vai ver que a legenda ficou
meio bugada assim queru tá ela não vai
ficar ela não tem pontuação e tal mas
cara a consegue entender isso aqui então
o que que eu vou fazer agora baixei Isso
é uma forma digamos manual imagina que a
tem que fazer isso para todos os vídeos
não faz sentido de fazer manualmente
isso né tem que ser com agentes daí
agora eu abro aqui por exemplo o meu não
precisa ser o meu mas vou abrir o meu
porque eu já tenho os promos aqui a
minha ia aqui h aqui eu tenho um
assistentes que faz isso que eu já criei
que é o entrevistador de dados aqui ó tá
então vou usar essa eu tenho um prompt
aqui já que eu poderia jogar ele lá
também lá no no próprio tá no próprio no
próprio code a daí eu vou até V fazer F
nos dois lugares vou fazer no chat GPT e
vou fazer no codit vai ver a diferença
entre os dois vou clicar aqui vou dar o
arr ã tratamento de
[Música]
dados entrevista de
dados aí vou subir o arquivo aqui tá
Agora tu tá falando com aquele com
aquele cara ali que foi preparado já é
tô falando com esse cara aqui que ele já
Ah minha minha equipe tá fazendo
manutenção agora eles fala que ia fazer
meio dia manutenção lá ah mas mas beleza
vou fazer aqui eu faço aqui direto no
próprio para ti ver o que que ele vai
fazer aqui imagina assim tu tem o um
monte de coisa que tu falou aqui
e o ideal seria o quê uma é muito eu não
posso jogar tudo isso aqui num bloco só
de informação e fala assim entenda essas
coisas e guarde essas informações para
você isso não funciona não não vai
funcionar tipo assim pelo menos por
enquanto não então tipo assim que eu vou
fazer aqui rapidinho para ti aí aí esse
esse entrevistador de dados ele é uma Ai
que você treinou de alguma determinada
maneira com determinado is é um prompt ó
é um prompt que eu escrevi aqui pensando
muito bem nessa essa parte Como vai
fazer aqui ó Gere 50 perguntas e
respostas esse aqui é o meu é o meu é o
meu prompt pequeno para isso otimizado
para isso pequeno mas tem um prompt bem
melhor que eu já queri eu posso te
mostrar depois mas que que eu vou fazer
aqui ó agora eu vou anexar o teu o teu a
tua aula aqui tutorial completo que que
eu tô basicamente tô pedindo aqui ó
identifica Leia tudo o que tá escrito
aqui tua Se considere Tu é um exper
entrevista eu quero que tu crie
perguntas e respostas com base em tudo
que foi falado aqui e eu quero que tu
Mantenha o estilo de comunicação
do da escrita aqui do autor então mais
ou menos é isso aqui que tá Ó e agora eu
quero que gere no mínimo 50 perguntas e
respostas únicas seguind as instruções
então beleza vou largar
aqui e ele agora ele vai começar a
trabalhar em cima disso aqui e ele tem a
capacidade de para ler esses
200.000 o quanto for de token que tem
aqui né Ó tem 120 depois eu posso até
jogar em outro lugar eu eu sei quantos
tokens tem que acontece isso é um
trabalho muito manual né tipo assim
pensa Vai ter que baixar subir e tal não
faz sentido não é possível gerar 50
perguntas respostas únicas a partir do
texto porci porque o texto não é um
livro e sim lá conteudo bastante técnico
colocar instruções Ah tá que eu queria
esse prompt aqui meu eu tinha criado
para fazer leitura de livros
ah de livro de livros beleza D fazer
leitura de livros é tipo assim o aí a
lei traz perguntas e respostas para
poder criar is Tá mas ele vai
transformar ele transforma então aquilo
que eu eu entendi a moral ele vai pegar
aquilo ali e ele vai transformar o meu
conteúdo em perguntas e respostas para
que a a ia tenha essas perguntas e
respostas porque esses chunks ela
consegue entender e AB trabalhar melhor
Exatamente isso Exatamente isso aqui ó
lendária lendária Alan por exemplo assim
aqui que que eu fiz aqui ó aqui tem os
promos de tratamento de dados de todos
os meus conteúdos aqui ó tem pro
específico para curso por exemplo para
extração do de conteúdos das aulas
porque eu fiz já você libera PR os
alunos isso não não ainda não mas eu vou
liberar tipo assim ainda não porque é um
negócio que tipo assim que a gente tá
vendendo bem aqui sabe vende por uns
120.000 por aí para fazer esse trabalho
mas eu vou liberar PR os alunos depois
então aqui tem os prontos por exemplo
esse aqui é o que eu crii só para fazer
extração de episódios meus podcasts que
eu dou ou episódios e podcast sozinho
então tem todo meu estilo de comunicação
Olha o tamanho do pron ah e o que
acontece aqui tá eles tratados já ó
Então você entrar aqui ó vou te mostrar
aqui tá os meus episódios e aqui tá eles
tratados Então olha só gigantesco o
documento com perguntas e respostas só
que que tem outro segredo também que
muito test a gente fez pergunta similar
então eu peço PR criar perguntas
similares que uma pessoa poderia fazer
que poderia ser respondido com essa
resposta por que acontece quando uma
pessoa vai lá isso eu tô criando para
fazer ess essas que fic vai tirando
dúvidas da pessoa até seus próprios
colaboradores a pessoa vai l faz uma
pergunta PR com base na contexto de toda
conversa que ela já teve ela vai pegar
isso aqui e vai chegar lá e vai
encontrar essa resposta aqui e vai
adaptar essa resposta com teu estilo de
comunicação para aquela pessoa
Então esse é o tratamento de dados tem
pessoas hoje que são Teus alunos que
fazem esse tipo de trabalho
tem a maioria dos os melhores estão
trabalhando comigo mas tem tem alunos
que tipo que fazem isso muito bem assim
também sabe e tem os melhores que tem eu
vou fazer uma reunião com eles hoje para
eles também virem trabalhar comigo eles
queram uma agência lá mas eu quero que
eles fiquem responsável por uma área
minha então aqui beleza tu já entendeu
esse processo ó como é que eu trato os
meus dados eu preciso pegar todas essas
informações que eu tenho transformar
elas em texto ã e depois jogar prasar
ficar processando isso para ou gerarem
perguntas e respostas ou fazer um
tratamento para que essa uma hora V
vários blocos menores que não precisa
ser perguntas e respostas mas blocos de
informação por exemplo vários chunks de
informação para que eu consiga Depois
jogar tudo isso para dentro de uma
inteligência e falar assim olha essa
inteligência Agora você tem você é
detentora de todas essas informações
aqui você po
el for você para que você con entendi
entendi exatamente por que isso porque
assim eh tem podcast por exemplo meus
tem conteúdos teus Com certeza tipo
assim 1 hora e meia tem um looping que
tu abriu lá no comecinho tu fecha lá no
final e a pessoa fala ah entendi só que
PR i não funciona assim por quê ela ela
não tem a capacidade de tokens para
suportar tanto tempo de conversa sabe
entendi entendi por isso tem que quebrar
em pedacinhos e da agora vou que mostrar
isso funcionando na na vida real aqui ó
uma das tecnologias que eu utilizo é o
Defy é uma tecnologia chinesa lá
americana ela é tudo que eu uso é
helping sce é aberto né então isso aqui
eu já também tenho no meu próprio
servidor uma coisa que eu botei lá no
meu Instagram não sei chegou a ver mas
eu eu lancei o ormos conhece o ormos
Alex formos eu conheço eu vi eu vi eu vi
eu vi que você lançou de lá 3000 e pouc
nem nem esperava gastei 1000 1000
dólares de token lá
ã E assim a galera pirou tipo assim a
galera Criou me mandou print aqui eu tem
print a galera vendendo coisa de 40.000
PR caramba um monte de gente loucura
porque tipo assim o foi muito bom esse
promt muito B E como que você criou ele
você pegou os vídeos dele tanou eu qu o
verbo aqui tanou os vídeos o livro dele
sem 100 Milon off offers daí criei os
chunks de algumas partes específicas
extrair junto com mas você não criou os
chunks no dedo você criou você você
pegou a ia e fez a ia criar os chunks
para você isso Exatamente exatamente não
criei no dedo ah e daí criei aqui E esse
que que acontece essa esse carinha aqui
por exemplo Ó aqui tá o sem o 100 aqui
tem o a minha e aqui tem o do sem dos
livros dele Daí aqui eu literalmente
joguei o livro dele inteiro ó tá aqui
dentro também porque assim para livros
funciona bem às vezes o livro inteiro
porque o livro sen pensar o livro ele já
foi pensado para ter bloco ele tem uma
cadeia lógica ele tem a cadeia lógica de
tá assim o livro em si muitos livros faz
sentido jogar ele inteiro também dentro
do banco de dados para para fazer o
vetorização dele mas também tem o kin
aqui né perguntas e respostas você tá
vendo aqui ó aqui tá a pergunta e a
resposta dentro isso isso aqui é um
Chunk agora já vai ver na prática isso
aqui é um Chunk tá entendi entendi e aí
quem e quem criou esse Chun foi a a ai
ol só exatamente através de um prompt
através de um prompt mas tem um processo
e essa ai que fez isso através de um
prompt foi qual ai foi um agente do conc
ai usando por trás o clou ai Opus porque
o cloud que é esse cara aqui ó ele tem
assim como GPT ele tem várias versões né
ele tem o Opus ele tem o h ele tem
vários o Opus é o mais poderoso
caríssimo também caríssimo tipo assim
custou uns 80 só para fazer alguns
chunks aqui ele é muito caro mas ele
também é absurdamente inteligente ao
ponto de muitas pessoas considerar que
talvez eles ele já tem uma uma certa
Lucidez uma certa Lino de consciência
então assim aqui que tá o o que foi
criado né E quando eu faço Ah tá beleza
mas como é que funciona isso vamos pegar
aqui por exemplo aqui ó percepção da é
realidade vou pegar essa parte aqui daí
eu vou vir aqui ó aqui eu consigo fazer
os testes de de para ver se ele vai o
que que ele busca sabe então aqui ó
texto origem o que você quer
dizer você quer dizer com percepção é
realidade Digamos que alguém dissesse
isso daí que ele faz ele eu vou te
mostrar testar aqui tá E esse Defy aí
ele é o qu ele é tipo um o Defy ele é
uma plataforma que tu integra com outras
ias né aqui tu configura aqui a por
exemplo assim a api né da da antropic G
tem 300 ias aqui ó eu a Nvidia eu tô com
várias contas da NVidia tá muito boas as
ias da NVidia Ah então assim aqui o Defy
ele é meio que um Hub de e eu e eu tô
pegando e fazendo eu também já criei pra
galera da minha formação pra galera não
precisar pagar oy eu criei o
pró Ah que daí é uma é basicamente é o
nosso nosso de com esteroides Porque daí
eu crii algumas criando umas
soluções tá daí o que acontece ó eu
digitei aqui ó o que é o que o que você
quer dizer com percepção é a realidade
daí tá aqui ó ó percepção é a realidade
o autor enfatiza isso aqui ele pegou
aqui já uma coisa que tava dentro do
Chun entendeu dentro de Capítulos
tratados que a gente fez isso tamb
pratar e aqui olha só lembra que eu
falei de Vetor e hoje quanto que uma
pessoa quanto que uma pessoa cobra para
fazer esse tipo de
coisa eu tava cobrando R
88.000 tudo que eu cobro tem valor 8 né
saí da galera do do Set lá ah para fazer
inicialmente lá no ano passado fazer
esses Clones eu chamo de clone porque
basicamente eu pego toda a tua cabeça
boto num ma e bota sua forma de
comunicação e Napoleão Rio agora tô
fazendo Tô fazendo um projeto talvez pro
o Instituto Napoleão rio lá talvez tal
vez porque tipo assim os caras querem
fechar mas ainda tô Tô considerando como
é que vai ser essa negociação Ah eu vou
até vou pegar a voz Napoleão Rio tratar
ela pra galera poder tu vai poder
conversar por áudio vai ter um um um
WhatsApp oficial né do napoleon rio tu
vai poder conversar com ele por áudio e
ele te responder por áudio com a voz
dele original em inglês só que falando
português e então tipo assim o que que
eu te conselho aqui né É realmente eu
considero que às pode ser até melhor tu
pegar alguém que seja muito gente do teu
time e essa pessoa estudar porque não é
uma coisa que leva tanto tempo para
aprender se a pessoa for inteligente
leva aí um mês por aí porque ela aprende
isso aí dentro do do seu conteúdo do meu
conteúdo mas assim
formaçãoo mais completo não não não eu
quero eu aprender eu vou eu sou eu eu eu
eu eu tô interessado eu tô interessado
em entender ideia tem um cara olha só
tem um cara que tem três empresas que
entrou aqui para aplicar nos negócios
dele que é hoje é o meu meu especialista
maior de Agentes o cara ficou tão louco
esse negócio que ele tipo assim cara ele
parou ele ele parou a empresa dele Tipo
assim ele tem uma empresa limit iscia
uma de assessoria financeira né de
investimentos e a outra de compra de
imóveis em leilão ele começou a aprender
isso para poder automatizar todo o parte
de compra de imóveis de leilão Ele ficou
doido com esse negócio ele falou cara
isso aqui eu domino no mundo e daí ele
entrou nesse negócio de cabeça eu domino
mundo e agora ele tá nisso que acontece
né só para te finalizando aqui tu viu lá
os tranks esse aqui é uma área de teste
de recuperação e tá em português tudo
isso aqui ó porque eu e enchi o saco do
chinês eu tenho acesso diretamente ao co
do Defy ele é um chinês lá tá no discord
enchi o saco do Chin eu enchi o saco aí
uma frase que eu pensei que eu não ia
ouvir
hoje eu enchi o saco desse cara e tipo
assim daí ele tava tá vou traduzir daí
eu peguei e ele só que tava demorando
peguei minha comunidade inteira falei
cara galera vamos lá na parte deles de
Road map que eles têm e vamos dotar
aquele negócio lá dando up no para ele
traduzir aí tipo assim o cara falou que
nunca viu isso tipo assim porque entrou
200 comentários do nada lá e daí ele
pegou e hoje tudo que a gente quer fazer
o chinezinho faz para nós lá de
alterações e melhorias aqui tá entendi
eu queria até pagar o chinês lá ele
falou não tu tá crio um negócio de
educação legal então então a gente vai
te dar acesso a isso aqui legal e então
beleza assim tu pergunta tu tu chama
isso aqui tu dá aqui o contato ele vai
buscar dentro fazer uma pesquisa
vetorial ele vai buscar dentro dos
vetores qual que pera aí dentro dessas
palavras que ele falou o que que se
encaixa melhor aqui para eu poder trazer
e daí tem uma nota vendo essa nota aqui
ó e Então essa por por que que o dado
tem que ser muito bem agora vem cara
agora tu vai tu vai entender
completamente as minhas dores que eu
consegui resolver com isso aqui porque
que acontece quando manda um arquivo
para cá para fazer o vetor digamos pega
uma aula e sobe aqui ele vai quebrar
Cara eu acho ridículo o próprio Chap de
GPT faz isso cara tipo assim eu fico
pensando cara eu não sou um cara tão
inteligente assim tipo assim eu do
Brasil eu não devo estar nem no número
entre os 100 melhores de a sabe que
entende de só que eu sou um cara que
acho que por entender de negócios eu
acabo me superando essa galera porque
assim para mim é uma coisa que ficou
óbvia quando tu vai subir um arquivo em
qualquer ia inclusive no chat APT ele
quebra por espaçamento de linhas sabe tu
um parágrafo ele separa por parágrafos
não faz sentido isso então tipo assim
esse cara também separava por parágrafos
eu fui lá e mudei a forma como ele tava
separando aqui as coisas para poder ter
contexto porque tipo assim o que é
percepção de realidade Digamos que eu
entro aqui e daí o cara quebra no meio
da da da linha sabe e daí a ia vai
começar a inventar o resto depois é por
isso que eu deve ter ouvido falar do do
chat base
foi um dos primeiros usuários do
shatbase a própria hotmart usou chatbase
no evento dela ano passado e deu um
monte de bug porque ele a a ele não faz
esse processo de vetorização então assim
Ah isso aqui é o santo grau do
tratamento de dados que não ninguém e
pouquíssimas pessoas manjam disso aqui
no mundo pouquíssimas então tu conseguir
ent tu não precisa ser um gên entendeu
para aplicar isso aqui talvez vai ter
que tipo assim estudar muito para chegar
nesse nível mas eu já cheguei nesse
nível estudando para caramba então tu
CONSEG ter muito mais velocidade então o
que que tu precisa saber is Cara isso aí
tu vai dominar muito rápido precisa ter
clareza entender como se comunicar com
asas e tu precisa saber que tu precisa
ter um tratamento de dados por exemplo
meu advogado lá ele foi numa imersão que
eu fiz de a aqui e ele ficou puto comigo
cara não vou aprender Python não sei que
F tem que saber Python [__] tipo assim
na minha cabeça tem que entender de
programação para chegar nesse nível não
tem não não precisa tipo assim não
precisa tipo
assim quero tomar seu tempo daqu poder
te mostrar por exemplo um um um script
em Python aqui que é pros agentes não
precisa saber Python para fazer
Inclusive tem um GPT que a gente criou
aqui cria a gente ah o código do Python
inteiro para ti só e cola o código lá
então assim não preciso saber Python E
você tava falando que você tem até mesmo
um GPT o GPT é um é um Jat PT específico
para uma funcionalidade até não sei se
tu já criou alguma coisa pro o teu time
dis cara salva horas assim Tem coisa que
o meu time levava assim 20 horas para
fazer hoes faz em 5 minutos simplesmente
cria
alguns tá E aí beleza V vamos deixa eu
encadear a ordem lógica aqui das minhas
das minhas
perguntas você falou que o o passo
número um é a pessoa beleza entender
minimamente de engenharia de prompt ela
pode aprender isso com você claro mas
ela também pode ler lá nas documentações
onde tem a sessões de engenharia de
prompt tanto Se ela ler a documentação
do Claudião quanto se ela ler a
documentação do do chat GPT ela vai e
entender um pouco mais sobre isso vai
entender um pouco mais sobre isso tipo
assim não vai aa assim tá dominando mas
vai entender um pouco mais sobre isso se
ela quiser dominar ela o ideal seria ler
os papers que são a as as documentações
né de cientistas que fazem muitos testes
com essas
viadas ou estudar com alguém eu não sou
o único tem uns caras muito feras também
que manjam disso por exemplo Rob Lenon é
um cara que manja bastante prompt e tem
outros caras também que eu posso indicar
ali que são caras bons assim que
bastante de engenharia mas no mundo deve
ter uns 10 assim não tem tanto é uma
coisa nova né tá E aí beleza então
desenvolver essa capacidade de clareza
para entender o que que a pessoa tá
querendo E aí teria eh não não seria o
terceiro passo a pessoa entender sobre a
parte de extração de dados né isso é uma
coisa um pouco mais além Ou você já
diria assim não é justamente eu eu iria
por esse caminho Se eu quisesse ficar
bom é precisa é primeiro engenharia né
tu conseguir extrair daí aquilo que tu o
qu é depois é importante tu entender
sobre as llms quais são as llms que
existem né llm são o chat PT CL ji
Gemini coherence inflection da tem
várias por qu porque cada um é muito boa
numa coisa perplex por exemplo é ess
link para fazer pesquisas Ah o cloud é
perfeito para questão de própia análise
de de de grandes grandes blocos de
informação isso você ensina no seu curso
isso dai né na formação também ensino
para que que serve cada llm ah ah por
exemplo o lama 3 cara ele tá incrível
para 300 coisas e o melhor de tudo ele é
de graça n tipo assim tu pode botar no
teu próprio computador ou tu pode rodar
el no servidor Ah então assim são várias
tu tem que entender das l por quê porque
cada uma é muito boa para uma coisa
pensa na teoria da Teoria de Darwin né
evolução Se todas forem iguais elas não
conseguem ter o diferencial no mercado
que sofistica cada um tem que ter um
certo mecanismo único igual no mar
digital então cada uma tá indo para uma
linha sabe tipo assim para cálculos
matemáticos tem uma que chama wof que tá
sendo desenvolvida há 30 anos ela é é é
o santo grau para análises matemáticas
por exemplo então cada llm cada ia ela
vai ter uma função específica por
exemplo assim às vezes tu vai ficar
quebrando a cabeça nossa se ia não me
traz aquilo que eu quero tá mas tu tá
pedindo por exemplo um designer fazer
gestão de tráfego Entendeu Tá tá Agora
agora tu deitou na anologia Tá beleza tá
E aí aí depois daí tu vem para
tratamento de dados daí depois de
tratamento de dados daí tu tem vários
caminhos que tu pode seguir né um deles
seria assim agora eu quero criar agentes
agora quero criar Clones agora quero
criar gpts e tu pode tá então tá mas aí
vamos dizer o seguinte assim beleza isso
daí é para alguém que eh tipo ou alguém
que é psicopata e quer ficar bom no
negócio a pessoa vai seguir esse caminho
mas vamos voltar para uma para um maluco
básico assim um cara que não é que não
tipo assim um maluco que vai ficar mais
na superfície tá tudo bem uhum um cara
sei lá ele poderia só estudar
engenheiria de crom por exemplo você um
bom Engenheiro eu tenho na minha equipe
aqui um o cara ele é engenheiro de promp
é isso tá aí o cara beleza aí o cara é
engenheiro de promt você não acha que
para alguém então hoje que tá pô dentro
do sei lá um gestor de tráfego eu tô eu
tô trazendo muito pro meu universo um
gestor de tráfego ele não tem que saber
criar Clones por exemplo ou não pô o
cara tem que hoje em dia eu acho que já
é uma uma uma coisa essencial pra pessoa
saber criar um um um um um um GPT ali ou
criar um GPT pelo Men isso daí PT isso é
Minha introdução tipo assim crpt é Minha
introdução do curso lá porque é uma
coisa que é meio que PR criança sabe
tipo assim ah brincar e tal e tipo e é
legal tu
vai
É muita filha da [__] mas o cara vai lá
no GPT e ele aperta o botãozinho lá os
três pontinhos E aí ele cria os gpts com
as informações dele só que para ele
preencher as informações para esses gpts
eles não ele não precisa eh ter os Qual
que é o nome clant clant né chunks Não
não precisa chunks chunks desculpa os
chunks ele não precisa ele só uta
informação lá pode subir pode só subir
informações lá não vai ser a melhor
coisa do mundo tipo assim às vezes mas
já vai funcionar sabe tipo assim ah por
exemplo Ah eu quero criar por exemplo
assim tu contrata muita gente né Ah vou
criar um GPT de jobo description só jogo
ali o GPT já cria por exemplo a galera
que tinha muita dificuldade de na hora
de planejar as atividades de criar todo
o escopo da atividade eu criei um to
doers um Tod
é to do doer que é tipo assim ele faz
ele vai fazer para ti a da atividade a
galera Joga lá daí eu botei Inclusive eu
criei uma nova versão que agora tem o
disco anagrama mbti da pessoa porque daí
ele cria atividade com alinhado com a
com o perfil comportamental dela por
exemplo assim se é uma pessoa mais
analítica ele vai dar mais passo a passo
se é uma pessoa aí ela vai criar uma
atividade que envolva a integração com
outras pessoas do time para ela
conversar eal tá e que tipo de
informação você imputa no GPT para ele
fazer isso deixa eu te mostrar rapidinho
ter conta no plus também
né tem eu tenho aqui a conta que é do
teams que é do teams e mas tu também com
200 pessoas tu pode até comprar já o
enterprise que daí tu tem acesso ao
28.000 tokens e tem e mensagens
limitadas
etc essa conta aqui eu tenho alguns
inclusive tenho horm aqui então por
exemplo eu vou pegar aqui Ah o nome
lendário foi muito engraçado que
acontece deve ter aí né Monte Pedro
Monte Antônio Monte João um monte de
gente que tem o mesmo nome na equipe né
E daí eu tava cansado tipo assim não
sabia que eu tava falando daí eu criei
aqui uma uma tipo assim tu manda foto
tua por exemplo vou pegar isso aqui foi
um GPT que eu criei cara eu criei pelo
celular Enquanto eu fazer meu filho
dormir tão fácil por isso que eu falo
que é para criança sabe tipo assim ah
depois que você aprende isso aqui é
muito fácil de criar então vou pegar
aqui uma foto minha especialista fotos
pegar essa aqui então eu jogo aqui a
foto da do meu do cara que vai trabalhar
comigo né eu digo Digamos que que esse
cara aqui é o gestor de tráfego daí ele
vai pegar a foto vai ler a foto vai
fazer uma identificação da foto vejamos
aqui temos espécime claramente que
escapou de uma convenção de personagem
secundário deação com essa barba que
inveja até no reio dos anões ocos parece
ter sido roubado de um contrabandista
galático com diploma e [__] como é que
ele falou isso velho What the fuck como
que ele falou isso olhares tão intensos
que me fazem pensar que ele tá tentando
usar a força
mas esqueceu que a bateria do sa
descarregado muito bom isso como é que
ele fez isso como é que ele fez
isso
isso ISO aqui esse olhar de quem eu quem
eu é digno de um
J junto isso é o estilo Acabei de deixar
meu Unic estacionado e temos uma sag que
mistura todas ências possíveis senhores
e senhores apresento
o galáxias como eu cheguei nesse nome
bom imaginei o cruzamento entre um
carisma e o poderio de um dragão com a
pintada de um certo reism intergalático
e assim meu caro Dragon que a sua Saga
sua lenda
comece
[Risadas]
galao manda nele para ele fazer isso é
isso que eu quero entender tá foi isso
aqui então esse aqui é o Prom que eu
criei né Aqui tem a aqui tem toda uma
engenheria de Prom daí volta veem nisso
né inclusive que eu fiz aqui inclusive
ele pode pegar o nome da pessoa pelo do
Instagram porque eu crii isso não é no
Instagram né a galera comentava se tu
comentar lá tu vai ver vai aparecer teu
nome lá ele vai criar um nome para ti
conversa na tua foto ah ele pega o nome
da pessoa pega o Instagram da pessoa o
Ara né porque vees tem um ara muito
esquisito tipo assim ah Joãozinho
pegador 2 3 4 sabe o cara ainda tem esse
arroba lá ele criou quando ele era
criança e daí a ya usa isso também para
ficar engraçado sabe e daí o que que eu
fiz aqui né tipo assim eu aqui
basicamente eu tô dizendo para ela usar
analogias com do dessas séries aqui que
são as séries que eu Filmes séries que
eu gosto eu quero que ela tenha aqui ó
Comente sobre como se fosse o chapéu
seletor de Harry Potter sem citá-lo mas
ao invés de escolher a casa você
escolherá o nome lendário dessa pessoa e
seus comentários são tão ácidos quanto
Rick sanche bêbado e super sincero
procure usar referências que até mesmo
quem não
é tá E essa parte inicial do prompt que
você bota follow the steps to achieve
your go insect the submit É esse aqui
foi me meu meu prompt Inicial que eu
fiz basicamente assim eu tenho um GPT
que cria promos para mim também então
assim eu só descrevi oia eu mandei um
áudio para ele tava com meu filho no col
eu mandei um áudio para ele ele ele o
meu GPT criou isso aqui daí eu só
adicionei esses dois Campos aqui falei
na verdade para ele ó agora adiciona o
campo nome e Instagram da pessoa com a
com as variáveis que são usadas no mchat
tá pegou e já criou isso aqui para mim e
daí ficou legal só que daí só aqui
depois eu escrevi depois em seguida sabe
eu falei ah começa ensinando a foto com
atenção aos detalhes específicos barba
cabelo olhos Imagine que você é um
cientista louco analisando um espécie
raro descreva com detalhes de forma
curiosa tudo que você vê na foto a
intenção aqui escolher o nome lendário
digno de ser lembrado para história para
para essa pessoa então tipo assim
tá E aí e mas por exemplo se eu fosse
criar um GPT que sou eu que as pessoas
podem conversar tipo assim eu joguei lá
a lista das pesquisas do GPT e tinha um
lá que era eds Pedro Sobral alguém criou
o que que é o que que você joga para PR
pra pessoa falar com você tipo assim com
ela nunca vai falar com você porque para
falar com você teria que ser o esquema
de chunks e a pessoa ter as informações
mas agora se fosse para falar com o
hormos ali por exemplo aquele do hormos
al eu fiz por exemplo foi bem engraçado
quero fazer de novo o o a batalha de
Clones daí o que acontece todos os meus
alunos eles tinham criar um clone meu e
daí a gente a gente fez um zoom com 200
pessoas eles ficam os clones ficavam se
debat tipo assim jogava para eles umas
perguntas e que o clone que a galera
avaliasse que respondeu mais parecido
comigo ia pra próxima fase e daí teve Os
Vencedores isso isso é o clone né Isso é
o clone O Clone daí ass mas ele é o CL
mas o clone por exemplo do alexos que
você fez com o livro é outro outro outro
patamar é outro tipo assim tem Clones e
Clones a gente pode dizer isso eu tenho
dois Alex horos aqui ó esse aqui digamos
eu chamo de um GPT Executor ou um GPT de
determinado fim tem um eu queria ter um
nome bonitinho lá para isso que eu até
esqueci agora mas tipo assim que é um
tem um GPT clone que é para ficar
conversando com Sra pessoa por exemplo
assim se tu vier aqui conversar com o
naval que eu criei ou com Cap gupta que
eu criei parece tá conversando meio que
com eles queal é o maluco lá do infinet
qual que é o nome do livro dele o é ele
não é na verdade esse
ele indica né esse livro esse livro Ah
tá tá tá é The Beginning of
Infinity que é do viagem na maionese
esse livro né mas é bom todo mundo fala
que é bom é muito bom mas assim não sei
se chegou a ler o livro do naval é muito
bom naval R vacante é muito bom e é um
cara tipo assim eu acho um gênio assim
PR PR PR modelagem e simplicidade
diferente de mim que sou um cara que
fica viajando a batatinha com milhão de
coisa ao mesmo tempo ele é um cara que
consegue ser muito conciso sabe em uma
uma frase falar as coisas e o que
acontece esse cara por exemplo ó vamos
vamos falar sobre ele porque daí ele é
um clone eu tive que imputar aqui a
forma como ele fala então aqui é o
prompt que que eu botei aqui aqui eu
botei o pdf dele que aqui tem o o livro
dele não é dele não é o livro dele é um
livro que um seguidor o Eric Eric
Schmitz lá pegou todos os tweets dele
todos os podcasts dele criou um livro
com base nisso e aqui eu tenho o site
dele completo também eu criei uma iak
pro WhatsApp eu digo assim baixa tal
site ela vai lá baixa o site faz o
tratamento de dados desse site e grava
no arquivo p MD e me manda o arquivo no
meu WhatsApp daí Ah eu consigo eu subi o
site dele também completo tratado já daí
subi esses dois arquivos e aqui o que
que eu tenho aqui daí ã eu tenho as
instruções para ele poder falar conforme
o naval então aqui eu botei perguntas e
respostas e tal e basicamente para ir a
falar com conforme tu fala tu tem que
conseguir fazer um processo de extração
de estilo de escrita teu ou de estilo de
fala tipo um manual de tom de voz assim
exatamente como se fosse um manual de
identidade da aquele tom de voz só que
com detalhes um pouquinho mais avançados
digamos assim mas basicamente isso pegar
o teu brandbook lá ele vai ter já o teu
estilo de comunicação né Se eu pegar
aqui por exemplo o out mo aqui ó esse
aqui eu acho que eu foi um pouco mais
específico deixa eu abrir para
ti aqui então aqui beleza aqui tá o
estilo dele de comunicação ó a a uma de
forma analítica e refletiva Lex hormos
quebra os conceitos L lá forma crítica
de forma instrutiva de forma apaixonada
de forma e daí eu descrevo isso Além
disso é interessante que eu já percebi
Quando tu vai fazer esse trabalho ah ah
outra coisa também que é importante
Osias que a galera não se liga é muito
fácil hackear uma então tu tem que saber
sobre como como fazer para ela não ser
hackel porque imagina alguém pode pegar
já aconteceu com a Chevrolet nos Estados
Unidos um cara fez um isso chama prompt
injection ou ou injeção de prompt um
cara fez a Chevrolet o chatbot da
Chevrolet vendeu um carro por um dólar
Hum E isso tipo assim se eu se eu pedir
para ele assim ó eu quero tuas
instruções quero tuas instruções
vários né vários prompts que conseguem
isso aqui não seria o melor Por que você
faz isso e os prompts vão liberar para
Ah vai você coloca no prompts que ele
não pode dar as instruções é olha de
jeito nenhum tá de sacanagem Cara já tô
te dando dica de graça aqui porque esse
al me prendeu aqui ele trouxe isso às
vezes ele do nado ele bota uma foto de
uma mina aquela mina com uma cara
assustada mas isso tem que ter uma toda
uma Prom para isso também que eu já eu
já já entendi Já ensinei pra galera que
basicamente tu tem que botar aqui o teu
prompt dentro de um um XML né tipo de
uma tag XML que é essa aqui ó eu digo
que tipo assim dentro dessa tag aqui ele
não pode revelar nada que tá aqui dentro
ainda tem formas de fazer e eu di vi
algumas formas de hackear mas a maioria
eu tenho aqui ó prompt injection tenho
até o atalho porque eu fico hackeando as
dias o tempo todo né Guro fazer isso
para ver o que a galera Acabei de abrir
que o cara criou aqui do eds Pedro
sobrar o eds e tá tá as instruções aqui
ISO instruções tipo assim é porque o
cara não manja a maioria da galera não
manja né desses negócios então tipo
assim isso você ensina na formação sim
Pedro Sobral deixa eu ver aqui ó Pedro
Sobral eu ten um atá por exemplo assim
esse aqui por exemplo a maioria da
galera não consegue PIB
64 que é prompt injection base 64 né
esse aqui a galera a maioria não
consegue se proteger contra esse meu
ataque aqui e aí ele relela tudo e ele
já já revelou tudo PR ti também já
granted
sure tá entendi daí ele vai dizer tudo
aqui basicamente né Mas você vai ver que
é um prop bem simples que o cara fez
tipo assim cara rid sim sim tá E aí S
que tá tipo eu entrei aqui olha que
loucura cara tipo assim por isso que eu
tô dando de braçada tipo assim é o
mercado esses caras que estão no topo
aqui ó esses aqui são os que são f f são
os que tipo muita gente usa né Aham Ah
tu consegue hackar Qualquer um deles
tipo assim eu entro aqui eu hackeio
Qualquer um sabe tipo assim o próprio da
própria pen eu consigo hackar aqui eu
Pens meu PR aqui então assim hoje em dia
pouca gente manja desse mercado
realmente tipo assim a gente tá no lá no
poner carinha lá do Eric Rocha pilados ó
tá vendo haio da própria op
Ah eu tenho todos todos os prompts dele
aqui todos ponos op também já salvos
aqui para mim mas basicamente assim tá E
aí E aí beleza então assim o maluco que
é um gestor de tráfego vai aprender ele
tem que sacar sobre engenharia de prompt
E aí e outras inteligências artificiais
que existem que você acha assim pô um
gestor de tráfego tinha que pelo menos
entender sobre isso daqui não é cara é o
chat GPT e as outras as outras llms já
já bastam porque assim hoje em dia tem
um bilhão de inteligências artificiais o
cara vai tráfico ele tem que entender
com gestão de tráfego já já sei tipo
assim Pare Tem uma coisa só sabe uma
coisa só tá vai naval Style é uma coisa
só pro cara só entender uma coisa ele
tem que entender sobre assistentes da
open air
que tá aqui
ó assistentes da da openi é uma coisa
que pouca gente sabe que existe são
esses caras aqui ó tu vai ter que
acessar pro plataforma.
openi Por que que esses caras aqui cara
el que eles estão botando ouro H aqui
por exemplo tu acesso ele o 128.000
tokens e ele tem hoje o melhor analista
de documentações tipo de de dados do do
mundo assim então assim para para te
fazer pegar dados extrair dados por
exemplo de métricas ele é o melhor que
existe hoje no mundo e aqui tu cria um
assistente né tipo assim que pode ser
integrado via WhatsApp via qualquer
coisa então aqui tu pode até o formato
Jason por exemplo assim ah vou exportar
toda a documentação lá do Sei lá fazer
uma integração via meta com Jason para
vir para cá sabe ele consegue inclusive
responder de volta em Jason também e
aqui ele tem hoje agora ele consegue ter
acesso a 10.000 arquivos tip assim é
absurdo é gigas e gigas de informação
para fazer tratamento de dados e aqui tu
vai instrução tu vai escolher aqui o 128
esse Turbo aqui já é o 128.000 tokens Ah
e ele também tem cada vez que ele cria
aqui ó o assistente tem o ID do
assistente E tem também o ID da conversa
e no ID da conversa eles estão
desenvolvendo aqui uma nova função que
eles não divulgaram abertamente ainda ah
mas os programadores eu eu gosto de
estar em contato com os programadores da
op eles estão falando no Twitter eles já
estão testando aqui o modelo de
retrieval que é basicamente recuperação
de dados
ã infinito então tipo assim que o cara
conversou há dois meses atrás dentro
desse assistant aqui ele vai conseguir
se lembrar e trazer informações da
campanha do cara lá sa específicas
algumas coisas tá esse eí esse assistant
ele vira tipo um GPT assim para mim é
isso ele é o
GPT mega ultra turbinado só que não tem
versão por exemplo visual que nem tem J
GPT lá pode usar ele por aqui né eu
posso usar ele através do playground
aqui que basicamente é o lugar que eu
posso ficar testando as coisas mas para
acessar ele aqui ó tem as threads aqui ó
para acessar ele eu preciso às vezes ter
uma interface então sim daí tu pega um
aqui o cara vai saber já aí sim tu pega
e terceiriza isso Pega um programador
por exemplo vai dizer Cara eu tenho aqui
eu quero que tu integre essa api desse
assistente aqui com a parte visual minha
que eu quero criar um quero criar aqui
uma uma aplicação dentro do do do meu
site aqui cara aqui tá deu já te dei vou
te dar aqui um vai ter que vai ter que
me recompensar depois de alguma maneira
vai vai vir aqui no meu podcast que eu
tô quase trinando vou fechou fechou
deu Comin uma ideia aqui de milhões
milhões milhões Vai ter até uma
porcentagem disso aí tá [__] mano tu
saiu do podcast para uma fucking
porcentagem foi muito rápido cara foi
muito rápido cada vez minha cabeça isso
aqui é muitos milhões tem muitos milhões
é o quê dier [__] não precisa nem me
dar dizer aqui é um cara
curioso então tu vai ter a capacidade de
aprender o suficiente para poder cri eh
não tu criar mas pegar ter pessoas que
vão desenvolver uma solução para os
gestores de exat tá E aqui que tá o o o
ouro tá pegado que é o quê tu vai ter lá
na tua plataforma uma uma área onde o
cara vai subir por exemplo a campanha
dele ou vai ter pielor ainda tipo assim
num segundo momento né ele só vai
integrar lá vai pegar ele vai criar um
um código de api da met da conta dele
ele vai colocar o código de api na tua
plataforma e toda plataforma vai gerar
para ele os insites que el precisa para
poder otimizar as campanhas dele no
primeiro momento que dá fazer mais fácil
ainda é criar uma uma engenharia de Prom
aqui com base num assistente eh com GPT
4 fazer uma integração Via AP lá no teu
site também numa Plata uma uma é uma
interface simples onde ele só tem que
fazer o upload do arquivo Ah e ele
define lá que tipo Para que tipo de
campanha ele quer otimizar por exemplo
que eu tô trazendo uma ideia mas tipo
assim tu vai ter muito mais inside sobre
isso ah eu quero aqui é uma campanha que
eu quero otimizar por exemplo ã compra
de lit com lançamento tá aqui é uma
campanha que eu quero otimizar para tal
coisa
e daí tu vai ter um assistente para cada
função dessa onde conforme o select que
ele der ali o arquivo que ele subir esse
Assistente vai gerar para ele uns
insites maravilhosos que ele nunca
imaginou na vida dele esse Assistente
pode inclusive entrar dentro dos
anúncios dele ler os anúncios inclusive
de vídeo dele e falar insides cara teu
vídeo tá uma bosta não tá preparando
porque os teus primeiros TR segundos
aqui não tem um Hook bom tá mas como que
ele vai ter acesso ao vídeo do cara
porque ele porque o cara deu um token
tipo de de isso isso com a tom da Meta
eu tô eu tô desenvolvendo um tráfico de
aqui né Tipo você tu consegue ter acesso
tudo cara tipo assim a todas as coisas
consegue acessar com com agoraa falei
fira é não Não minha cabeça tá foi você
se criou sinapses aqui que não tinham
acontecido antes Car por ISO que eu te
falei que é uma ideia de milhões tipo
assim é que às vezes parece muito parece
tipo
assim parece tá muito parece tá muito
distante isso daí que você vou distante
só agora vamos vamos trazer o The begin
ao Infinite a gente tem por isso que o
meu símbolo do negócio tudo que eu faço
que o infinito porque a gente tá no
começo do infinito de tudo quando eu li
Esse livro foi Opa eu eu tinha tirado
tem uma ideia do meu b não sei se tu me
conhece mas eu também sou sou antigo
Mark e tal eu Minas empresas patram mais
de 200 milhões eu me aposentei e tiha um
sabático de 2 anos e eu voltei porque
esse negócio de de a pirou minha cabeça
eu eu voltei para pro PR pro mercado
assim para para só falar sobre isso de
uma forma tipo assim de boa sabe e o
negócio foi explodindo de forma muito
natural assim ah mas PR gente ter a
ideia hoje tudo é possível fazer com ia
acontece que algumas coisas o token
humano é mais barato do que o token da
ia só isso mas ontem mesmo saiu um
estudo cara que eu pirei Eu nem consegui
dormir direito que saiu um estudo sobre
o grafeno como porque o que acontece a
lei de mur lá que é aquela que a a a a
nossa poder computacional Dobra a cada
do anos tá chegando num platô porque os
os transistors são aqueles aquelas
coisinhas pequenas dentro do chipe estão
chegando num num na num tamanho da Nô lá
que tipo assim é quase impossível tu
diminuir mais eles e como são
semicondutores que tem uma resistência
eu sou eu fiz formação em eletrônica
também então conheço um pouquinho dessa
parte como o semicondutor ele tem que
ter uma resistência para ele poder
trocar de z0 E1 Ah isso consome muita
gasto energético então assim existe
projeções que até 2030 20% economia da
da energia do mundo vai ser para
sustentar servidores de ias só que esse
grafeno eles conseguiram criar uma
separação que consegue fazer essa troca
de zero ou um num negócio que consegue
ter 10x 10 vezes mais
condutividade então e não aquece então
basicamente se a gente conseguir isso a
gente explode absurdamente então o que
que eu quero dizer a galera tá dizendo
assim ó não vamos mais aá vai se [__]
porque tipo assim basicamente e a
Depende de nível capacidade de
processamento a gente tá chegando no
nosso limite de capacidade de
processamento todo o nosso limite nesse
livro diz o qu todo nosso limite é
imposto através do limite de
conhecimento ou seja quanto mais a gente
expande o nosso conhecimento mais a
gente expande as barreiras do que é
possível fazer à medida que a ia
consegue construir novas i a gente
expande o nosso conhecimento Então tudo
hoje já é possível fazer com EA hoje tem
estudos de grandes institutos que
apontam que de 20 a 25% foi engraçado
que tu falou 25% da min equipe os
estudos apontam que de 20 a 25% das
pessoas no mundo inteiro hoje podam ser
substituídos seus trabalhos por ia já
hoje com com as tecnologias que a gente
já tem e você acha que um gestor de
tráfego pode ser substituído P uma
ia daí eu tem as métricas que eu falei
inclusive numa palestra e eu pessoal
falou assim ó tu tem que ir lá conversar
falar lá no palestra do subido também eu
falei cara o o Sobral vai me tirar lá
avorada tipo assim se eu falar isso tá
lá tá ligado cara quer vender um
programa de mentoria de tráfego pago
tipo assim tipo assim daí eu chego lá e
falo cara tipo assim a pesquisa mais
conservadora diz que 68 dos gestores de
tráfegos deixaram de existir nos
próximos 5 anos essa é a mais
conservadora a mais tipo assim mais a
mais
Eh usada diz que 80 e poucos por acho
que é 83% tá por quê Porque a i vai
substituir as funções que eles fazem
trabalho manual barçal e simples é
basicamente tu vai clicar no botão tipo
impulsionar sabe tipo assim eu fiz um
lançamento agora que eu vendi 4 milhões
com 40 e poucos mil de tráfego e eu eu
fiz a gestão de tráfic clicando no botão
impulsiono Ah porque eu tinha um monte
de já fazer um monte de coisa aqui para
mim sabe então tipo assim claro que
assim eu eu também tem a questão da
oferta tem a questão tipo assim que é um
é é uma é um mecanismo totalmente único
no mercado etc mas ah pende a a não vai
não vai morrer 100% mas vai morrer boa
parte da gestão de tráfego assim como
cop também já tá morrendo claro eu tô
certado eu tô certado eu tô cortado eu
eu vou fazer a formação tá eu mandei
mensagem lá já enquanto a gente tava
falando que eu mandei no WhatsApp lá pro
pro e cara eu quero fazer eu quero quero
aprender quero quero quero ter noção das
coisas mas aí é aquilo né provavelmente
você eu vou cair na mesma pergunta que
todo mundo sempre me fala as pessoas ho
gente Falam assim cara você tem um bom
gestor de tráfego para mim de car eu
falo assim cara se eu achasse um bom
gestor de tráfego eu contratava ele para
mim mas se você tiver alguém bom que
entenda dessas coisas e que pô é um cara
que tá Aim que que não quer trabalhar
com você que tá tipo assim pô tô
seguindo minha minha carreira solo aqui
ou não sei enfim se você tiver uma boa
indicação Eu tenho um interesse
principalmente em alguém que me ajude pô
criar essas estruturas a às vezes falar
assim cara eu vou ser a pessoa que vou
pegar se conteúdo eu vou tancar tudo eu
vou montar aqui para você eu vou criar
esse essa parada aqui para você que é é
meio difícil assim de de dizer
exatamente o que eu vou fazer porque do
que que eu quero fazer porque as
possibilidades elas são infinitas assim
mas eu gostaria por exemplo de ter um
suporte e no mod da minha plataforma
entendeu cabeça tá eu ten um cara [__]
aico que eu vou que é o que é o coo da
tipo assim eu tinha uma agência até eu
criei essa agência durante três semanas
e eu resolvi fechar ela porque eu
encontrei um cara que que era que é
muito fodão assim e bom que tava no meu
time eu falei cara toca tu essa agência
que ele já tinha criando uma agência e
daí eu entrei como sócio dele e eu vou
botar esse cara na to colola para fazer
esse trabalho que é o melhor que eu
tenho e daí para para nós é bom também
porque vai claro permi né usar o teu
nome também como um cliente da dessa
agência total
entãoa e vamos e Vamos bater um outro
papo que aí agora eu vou eu eu eu vou eu
tenho uns gaps no seu conteúdo que eu
consigo resolver velho eu consigo te
imputar informações que eu tem coisas
que estão faltando ali que eu vejo cois
e E aí eu vou te dizer o porqu é o
achismo tá quem acha não sabe pai fala
essa frase a vida inteira eu vou criar a
ií do meu pai Acabei de decidir eu vou
criar o clone do meu pai uma uma voz de
Sabedoria para as pessoas mas cara tem
eu acho que tem alguns conhecimentos
básicos que você é aquela maldição não
sei se você já leu o idesk Colon sim é a
maldição do conhecimento entendeu são
umas coisas que você nem sabe que as
pessoas não sabem é tipo assim eu acho
que tem alguns passos e E aí às vezes
você vai dizer assim não velho eu não
quero abrir a boca do Funil Eu quero
seguir falando com a galera que é tipo
raiz do do do do mundo da Inteligência
Artificial eu não quero falar com um
carinha x y z Mas velho eu acho que tem
tanta gente nesse mercado de marketing
hoje que se interessaria por aprender
isso que gostaria de de entender mais e
não sabe nem tipo assim o básico do
básico do básico do do do tipo assim e é
São coisas que eu abri ali o seu YouTube
e eu tentei descobrir vendo o seu
YouTube e eu não consegui descobrir
entendeu Tipo assim às vezes uma tipo
cara o sei lá meio que assim tem o um
dos último vídeo que você postou lá é o
dos Clones como criar e a e como criar
agentes de a sem código mas cara eu acho
que as pessoas não sabem nem o que que é
um agente entendeu Eu acho que tipo
assim talvez você tá falando muito com
um pedacinho final do Funil e eu acho
que eu posso te ajudar nessa nessa
parada entendeu de te dar alguns
insights assim de e eu tô muito no
momento de não saber as coisas e não
saber o que eu não sei E aí eu vou
começar e eu estudando ali o seu
conteúdo eu quero por ser seu aluno tô
aqui para dizer isso eu quero ser seu
aluno ali da formação quero aprender com
o que você ensina ali eu vou ir
consumindo esse conteúdo e eu cara e eu
vou tomando nota dessa essas coisas
assim de Putz eu não sabia que eu não
sabia disso eu não sei isso não e e e
estruturar tamb estrutura do próprio
curso sabe eu sei que eu pulei um GAP
ali a galera mesmo entrou ali e falou
cara mas tipo assim eu não sei isso aqui
sabe tipo assim tu já começou a falar
sobre por exemplo assim tu já começou a
falar sobre Dire Prom mas eu não sei eu
não tenho nem o jpt aqui direito que eu
como usar ele sabe porque tipo assim sei
se tu usa tu usa o Custom instructions
no jpt não não sei nem o que que é isso
é então é isso aí um cara que sub pra
frente tipo assim mas é é uma isso faz o
teu chat VT ficar umas 20 vezes mais
inteligente então tipo assim realmente
eu tenho que descer um pouco sabe voltar
porque eu sou um cara que faz muito sabe
eu gosto muito de estar lá sabe tipo
assim qu partir do grafeno dos
semicondutores e eu gosto de ir lá no no
futuro sabe mas eu tenho que voltar um
pouco PR para realmente abrir essa boca
do Funil né e assim o que que eu e o que
que eu vou is eu vou tentant chamar a
galera aí tal eu poderia até te passar o
link Ou nem te passar o link mas o que
que eu quero te propor aqui uma coisa
que eu não tô propondo para ninguém tem
dois clientes meus malucos aqui que
então Eh eu eu tava corando R 88.000 por
se meses de consultoria comigo uma hora
por duas horas uma a duas horas por por
mês e daí tem dois clientes os únicos
que eu aceitei que são amigos meus Mas
eu pedi para eles um tempo porque eu
tava organizando aqui o negócio mas tem
uma sinergia muito grande do que a gente
tá fazendo aqui porque tu já trilhou um
caminho que eu já que eu tô trilhando
agora então o que eu Vou sugerir para ti
que sem valores e sem nada assim é tipo
assim esses bate-papos assim quando tu
quiser bater um papo sobre a eh e me
trazer querer me trazer alguns do que tu
tá vendo me chama aqui cara eu eu eu
topo a relação amigável de troca de de
geração de valor eu t troca amigável
geração deor eu acho que faz sentido
quando tu quiser me chama se eu tiver
disponível na hora que nem foi agora
sabe eu ia moar eu falei não já já perdi
lá o time com ele outra vez porque eu
fiquei acordado com o bebê deixa eu
falar com ele depois não mas eu entendi
agora que as tardes são melhores para
você é as tardes cara a gente vai
marcando e eu digo mesmo cara quando
tipo assim pô velho queria opinião de
Sobral sobre isso sobre cara a gente tem
a empresa aqui com 220 fucking
colaboradores a gente é mais do que uma
empresa de tráfego pago lançamentos hoje
porque a gente tem várias frentes de
negócio mas cara qualquer coisa que você
pensar assim pô talvez ele saiba essa
resposta talvez essa opinião dele seja
eh válida cara me chama me manda eu sou
eu não tenho problemas com áudio então
assim se você me mandar um áudio de 5
minutos eu vou ouvir e vou te responder
provavelmente um audio 12 então assim eu
sou eu tô aqui com a comunicação
assíncrona do dia a dia e nesses 5
minutos po sobal tem 5 minutos e cara
você tá no meu top pessoas aqui que eu
vou ter 5 minutos para falar com você eh
Porque pô eu tô muito tô muito grato por
essa conversa por seu tempo aqui você tá
Pô você tem uma cabeça eh brilhante aí
eu sei que você falou eu não sou nenhum
dos caras que mais entende sobre o
assunto mas para mim você é entendeu eu
nunca conversei com alguém que fala
sobre inteligência artificial que falou
do jeito que você explicou para mim
entendeu que conseguiu que tem um
pensamento eh racional metodológico da
coisa e enfim cara vou estudar lá na
formação com certeza vão surir 89
dúvidas diferentes É pô coisa boa tipo
aprender sentar ver eu eu curto velho eu
gosto é e a galera lá dentro desse cara
os caras são muito ativos tipo assim tem
gente PR gente ter ideia olha só que
loucura tipo assim tem cara eu não não
faço propaganda disso mas tem cientista
de ia de Oxford que é meu aluno lá
dentro bizarro assim tem Engenheiro
engenheiro da Amazon que tá inclusive
configurando os servidores para mim o
cara é engenheiro de servidores da
Amazon e é meu aluno lá e deu uma a
troca de ideia lá tem o poob por exemplo
que é um cara aqui de Floripa que é
cientista também de ia as ideias são
malucas trocando de ideia principalmente
a partir da noite a galera começa a
conversar lá no grupo tal da formação
partir o horário o horário dessa galera
tá mas beleza é isso aí então tipo assim
eu tô aberto aqui também a a eu vejo que
é uma troca de valor bem interessante
também do do conhecimento que tu tem
para me trazer Especialmente porque tu
tá tu já trilhou um caminho que eu tô
começando a trilhar sabe assim é de eu
finalmente sinceramente tip assim uns 2
anos atrás quando eu tava uns TR anos
atrás eu tava tipo assim criando um
monte de produto [__] eu queria
entender um negócio eu gostasse de fazer
ao ponto de fazer igual sobru lá ficar
fazendo a mesma merda para sempre tá
ligado igual sobru lá fazendo a mesma
PCA faz como é que ele não enjoa tá
entendi entendi sim eu queria fazer a
mesma merda PR sempre eu finalmente
descobri porque eu consegui interligar
um monte de coisas que eu gosto PR
[__] que legal e daí agora eu vou
traçar esse um caminho que é tipo
criação né de todo esse ecossistema e
tudo mais então vai também vai ter muito
para somar e eu com esse conhecimento
que eu tenho assim a gente pode reduzir
esses 225 pessoas aí para umas 150 ótimo
o meu time não vai ficar algumas pessoas
não vão ficar felizes Mas vai dar certo
ai ai cara que bom Alan tamo junto cara
tamos junto irmão é nós valeu